this week's honest trailer is brought to
you by d d beyond register for free at
dnd beyond.com to start your adventure
[Music]
not too long ago before they redid
cruella and let you know joker was not a
bad fella ron howard gave old dr seuss a
new pass to explain why the grinch
always hated chris mass he explained why
the whos are so cloyingly pleasant the
awards they give out their obsession
with presidents which who sorts the mail
and which whose have more income then
they still don't explain why they have
such big philtrums that's the space
between your nose and lip look it up
but believe it or not the film gets
quite exhausting like eating a cake
that's just made out of frosting so on
with the trailer no further ado here's
jim carrey's grinch plus cindy lou too
how the grinch stole christmas
welcome to whoville a tiny town inside
of a snowflake that may be part of a
whole cinematic universe these little
nightmares may not know jesus but they
do worship christmas another minute
and it's turned them all into spiteful
jealous little breed monsters where the
only thing more shallow than their
morals is the gene pool i mean come on
they all have the same face and last
name would it kill him to pork a wat
from whatville or why from wyeville now
and then this is why you don't pass
first place with your cousin guys
everyone aboard this inbred little
snowflake lives in fear of the grinch
[Applause]
the third of jim carrey's wacky green
characters who would probably kill you
he grew up amongst the who's but he
doesn't share their beliefs or holidays
so let's just say he's hooish prepare to
relate to his seasonal anxiety and
depression but what if it's a cool prank
what if it's a cash bar am i just eating
because i'm bored
and love him simply by association with
his perfect dog who's a good boy yes man
yes you are yes but it won't take a cute
puff or a tragic backstory to get you on
the grinch's side just the knowledge
that his makeup took so long to put on a
cia agent had to train jim carrey out to
endure torture punch yourself on the leg
so
or or smoke smoke as much as you
possibly can so i was this grinch
[Laughter]
settle in for a tale narrated by the
white morgan freeman anthony hopkins he
cleaned out that ice box as quick as a
flash why that grinch he even took their
last can of who cash
about a determined little stalker named
cindy lou whose performance is so sickly
sweet they keep finding an excuse to
flush her down a tube
[Music]
she's up against an evil mayor who grew
from an eight-year-old bully to a grown
ass man buoy to a real life buoy but no
one involved in the film is more dark
and crooked then ron howard and his
cinematographer why is everything in an
angle and why is it all so nasty since
when did he become ginger tim burton
you remember the 69-page book nice and
the classic animated film but now the
story's run time is stretched out with a
bunch of physical abuse
jim carrey doing stick of varying
quality
and more barely contained horniness than
a mistletoe belt buckle did i have a
crush on the grinch well of course not i
didn't ask you that
wait why is it so horny ah
i thought this was for kids a key party
the whos are all swingers
[Music]
ew i don't want to see the grinch's oh
face oh
ah why does he have a grooty dr seuss
would never oh never mind he totally
would man clearly celebrates thick bus
let's see that grinch dumper one more
time
for the erotic pleasures of women
and men
so if you want to see a heartfelt
version of how the grinch stole
christmas watch the 26 minute special
from the 60s but if you want to capture
the mood of what's like to smoke sherman
a christmas parade watch jim carrey's
other creepy christmas movie
but if you want to watch a disturbing
revenge fantasy starring a carry watch
this film or just watch carrie they're
basically twins
starring
salad fingers
all i want for christmas are two huge
front teeth the only character i can
stand to look at host alone hooper star
there's always mary in the banana stand
hot for creature baby choda and home
improvment
jib wasn't supposed to pull the
tablecloth off that cleanly and just
kind of went with it
legend
things i hate about who
the grinch's small heart grew three
sizes that day symptoms of an enlarged
heart include shortness of breath
swelling and death please call your
doctor if you experience an excess of
christmas cheer this week's honest
trailer is brought to you by d d
beyond's battle for beyond subscribe to
ddb's youtube to join the battle
we wish you a merry epic christmas and a
more epically happy new year
when i step up in the place hey yo i
step correct wooha got you all in check